[Music]
and field of schemes Muse submitted by
JK for three meals a day
oh yeah yeah healthy buddy a farmer
killed himself to avoid prison for a
massive organic food scam this food
wasn't organic and he was selling it as
okay here I thought I thought everyone
knew that yeah that organic is just not
that organic so this farmer he was a
mastermind a B 142 million dollar
organic food scam and he spent most of
it on escorts and gambling in Vegas Wow
that's all the gambler pusseh can you
buy with the hardened the expensive
Connie he's had a good chunk to an
escort to pay for her breast
augmentation and paid to okay so he had
sexual relationships with three women
who lived in Las Vegas he paid more than
two hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars oh man for their work at his
companies and then it says that he
they're so rich he spent more than three
hundred and sixty thousand dollars in
Vegas and wait that's barely two million
oh no that's not even you know it's like
five hundred grand
no if you add yeah if you know that's a
million two hundred twenty-four each
escort right that's six hundred no total
yzq oh my god yeah so where did the [ __ ]
another 139 million go but then they're
also saying that 110 thousand dollars uh
he spent from a bank account that he
shared with one of the women Oh oh my
god a joint bank account what a smart
woman if I wonder if I am ever an escort
that's the kind of esker I want to be
yeah it's more you have your own bank
account shared with the dude that's
smart
yeah yeah they're saying that he spent
like I said breast augmentation surgery
foreign travel a vehicle and insurance I
wonder if escorting is like normal work
where you have to work your way up like
your horse sucking dick for like 20
bucks an acre
you start off like very expensive maybe
it just depends who you know and who
brings you into the game yeah cuz
imagine like a the Epstein kind of
escorts like they already started at the
top you're right like if you already
[ __ ] a prince your cuts probably a
lot of money it's not what you know it's
who you know
oh this so too everywhere huh yeah it
turns out this fool was obviously a
beloved husband of 39 years to his wife
Wow um and so she ended up releasing a
statement oh because by the way jivin
Cho he committed suicide yes okay yeah
he committed suicide because he was
being sentenced to a 10 plus year
sentence or in prison exactly and so
well he was found dead in a vehicle
inside the garage of his home um he was
61 years old I wonder if he did the
gasping you know when they put the dash
and bring it inside and uh he looks like
he loves hookers yeah he look at this
guy so between 2010 and 2007 he sold
more than one 11.5 million bushels of
grain damn more than ninety percent of
which he falsely claimed were grown on
certified organic fields in Nebraska and
Missouri and they're saying that his
crooked sales equated to seven percent
of all organic corn and about eight
percent of all organic soybeans grown in
the u.s. damn happy hitter the grain was
mainly used for feed for cattle or as
feed for ten millimeters or gun expects
that work exactly and chickens that
would produce meat and eggs so you
telling me all these hipsters might be
[ __ ] getting GMOs when I think that
they're actually getting organic soccer
yeah exactly and that's the thing that
like pissed off the whole like food
industry right now organic food industry
because they're saying like you just
[ __ ] tainted nobody knows the hippies
are vegan anyway but what if those
vegetables were on
Organic who's not in the feed yeah
unless they're just eating straight core
and that's all they eat mmm because I
mostly care about the like there's
certain there's a dirty 12 produce items
there's 12 produce items that like
you're supposed to like be hyper aware
of being organic because the pesticides
if you're eating too much of them blah
blah blah blah and I don't know all of
them I just know celery is one soul as
people doing a celery juicing diet thing
if you're doing it with regulars like
not organic celery then you're the way
you're giving yourself poisons even if
you wash it and all that yeah yeah
there's certain there cert that's good
look it up look up dirty 12 dirty 12
yeah there's a dirty 12 and I wanna know
the dirt and those are the ones that
you're supposed to buy organic and then
everything else is kind of whatever if
it's organic right yeah avocados wheat
corn pineapples all the good boy
oh wait these are the clean fifteen
thirty twelve versus the clean it'll
take got a scar geez that's like a
celery I mean as look it's like pirates
all right so these are the Dirty Dozen
list of produce with Dirty Dozen with
the most pesticides a residue so it's
strawberries mmm peanut Oh nectarines
b-schools grapes peaches these were kind
of good to everything I eat I know me
too
there's tomatoes celery everything sweet
bell peppers Wow like 90% of that list I
mean what are we supposed to eat those
are the ones you need is this buy
organic everything else is fine
especially the clean food 2015 is
avocado so it says that these are least
likely to contain pesticide residue
avocados
sweet corn pineapples cabbages onions
sweet peas papayas asparagus mangoes
eggplants honeydew's Kiwis can
cantaloupes
watermelon cauliflower and water no
broccoli no purpose but he got so hated
your foul today dude well I don't
understand because there's no watermelon
in either one it's clean that means like
for sure he could you don't have to buy
organic so like for sure you don't have
to buy organic avocados because you're
not likely to have pesticides but you
for sure need to buy organic celery
because that will definitely yeah but
the water my the other just in the
middle they need too much so how much
are you pursue me I eat watermelon like
it has a rind like you're not gonna eat
the rind so it's probably not that big
of it that should be fine - mm-hmm and
if you're buying seedless watermelons
what you are know that GMOs in there
because it's seamless mm-hmm that's all
the watermelons data by yeah I mean who
wants to eat the seeds well I do you
know really bad I don't think it is I
think everything is kind of genetically
modified like did you see like the
original banana and then you see it now
one carrot everything is like everything
everything's been modified everything
it's just I'm for organic produce I'm
more concerned about the pesticides
because I eat a lot of raw but don't and
don't you want no bugs in your in your
body I really eat a bug then it poison
oh yeah that's true and my tummy gets
you you probably won't be there yeah
ecoli but then you gotta wash you know
there's a whole movement of people
eating bugs now we know somebody named
Peter strip so that just eats all bugs
just he talked about that publicly or do
you just don't wanna I don't know if
he's ashamed of those people talk about
how cricket protein might be a payer
source of models for you guys
Tommy's brothers both his brother told
me you're the parent are they both are
both Power Rangers all right I know one
the family of Power Rangers but when I
meant to you guys barb over game Yoshi
but his little brother oh he's around
I mean bugs out that crazy it's like a
protein powder isn't it we did it
I'm now in the bug really in Mexico they
sell the crickets with Blair on board of
Mexico Beach I've never seen cricket
I've tried to give us that when we were
in Mexico and I was the only person that
didn't eat what part
I've literally never Street you gonna I
have no idea I don't know what part of
Mexico because my uncle would buy them
here it was because of the White House I
think so
do they have like a presidential house
that's like oh like for everyone no I
think that presidents just get their own
house like I don't think there's like a
White House where like the family move
Santa's there is a blue house in Korea
all this we think we will link that's
the president president he's blue da ba
dee da ba da what would you do with the
hundred million dollars me yeah that's a
lot of money disappear in Best Buy some
commercial real estate I would invest it
into like the the weed business cuz
that's growing and thriving maybe not
just CD of a strain of THC everything I
pay someone to run it for me cuz I have
no idea what the [ __ ] I'm doing I would
just hold on to it cuz I don't need to
invest me - I'm done you would just like
span 140 million will go fast know it
the way I'll spend on very slow you
think so wait there's two conversational
what's happening no sorry I try to
convince Joe not to just hold on to the
one before him Ellen cuz just gonna
depreciate he's got to put it in
something yeah if I had money like Kylie
Jenner does I would just be done but a
hundred forty million is not that much
that's all
that level you need to continue to work
to maintain the lifestyle you have
gotten used to over the years of gaining
that much money would you keep the same
level of lifestyle you have if you had
that kind of my hundred forty million I
could spend a million dollars a year and
I'll ask me one hundred forty years
exactly a lot of money to spend
that's why you got to put it somewhere
where just appreciate you gives you the
interest they just love the engine about
five hundred forty minute I'm out no I
win it what would you go and what would
you do I don't even know your by just on
out okay cool out on the boss someone
you would have to go you have to get
more security because the hell of people
are going to try to rob me but they're
not gonna know we're gonna dropping you
tell the grab no one else we have money
everywhere you will just close all your
social medias you yeah I don't exist so
if you would just disappear we know you
have that kind of money yes hook you up
will give you money will you give me 1
million yep thank you a million I mean I
don't know you that long I know you and
I love you how much do I get then oh I'm
looking you all the bags are all what
the [ __ ] well I've known her for you she
signed my marriage certificate you know
what if we make a hundred forty million
she's out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]